Buonasera. Dunque, le crociate. Come sapete tutti è un tema piuttosto complesso ed è
anche un tema che si presta a molti riferimenti attualizzanti, più o meno adeguati. Noi ne
parleremo per tre sere di seguito, il che può sembrare molto. In realtà riusciremo
ad abbozzare soltanto alcuni degli aspetti fondamentali dell'argomento e specialmente
questa prima sera io, prima di entrare nel vivo, penso che sia necessario tracciare alcune
coordinate molto generali di ciò che sono state le crociate, in modo che siamo sicuri
che stiamo parlando della stessa cosa. Cosa bisogna sapere delle crociate? Che tutti abbiamo
studiato a scuola, naturalmente, e dunque tutti ci ricordiamo che è un evento del Medioevo,
che ce ne sono state parecchie, cinque, sette, nove, sfido chiunque a ricordarsi esattamente,
ma comunque parecchie, numerate. Sono eventi sanguinosi, sono eventi che comportano un forte
conflitto tra l'Occidente cristiano e il mondo islamico. Sono eventi che la nostra civiltà
ha prima celebrato con grandissimo entusiasmo, all'epoca in cui si scrivevano poemi come la
Gerusalemme liberata. Poi sono eventi di cui più di recente ci si è vergognati un po',
perché si è recuperata anche il senso dell'enorme violenza che le crociate hanno comportato,
dell'enorme esplosione di odio per il diverso, dell'enorme esplosione di antisemitismo che
compare in Europa per la prima volta proprio durante le crociate. Ecco, adesso non so se
il vento stia cambiando, ma è una di quelle domande che è meglio non porsi, non stasera,
comunque. In ogni caso si tratta di vicende che fanno parte del nostro patrimonio collettivo
di occidentali. Che cosa bisogna aver chiaro per seguire il discorso? Uno, le crociate sono
in realtà una forma molto particolare di pellegrinaggio. Questa magari non è una cosa
così ovvia. Invece è così, le crociate sono un pellegrinaggio. Noi dobbiamo pensare
a un'epoca in cui i nostri antenati cristiani d'Europa occidentale davano al pellegrinaggio
un'importanza enorme. Vedo il professore Di Freddi che sorride, anche adesso il pellegrinaggio
sul cammino di Santiago era diventato una cosa importante e la radio lo trasmette. Però
noi dobbiamo pensare a un'epoca in cui il pellegrinaggio per i cristiani, specialmente
il pellegrinaggio in terra santa, era sentito quasi come può essere oggi per i musulmani
quello alla Mecca. Come un momento catartico straordinario, come il momento in cui chi può
vive per una volta in prima persona tutti i significati profondi e anche tutti i rischi
della sua religione. Dico rischi perché ovviamente appunto un conto era andare a pellegrinaggio
al santuario più vicino e un conto era andare in pellegrinaggio a Gerusalemme, sul santo
sepolcro. Vivere questa esperienza che per i cristiani del Medioevo era sentita come una
cosa fortissima di immedesimarsi con Cristo, poter dire lui è stato qui, io sto calpestando
lo stesso terreno che ha calpestato lui, ma naturalmente Cristo lì ha subito la passione e
allora il pellegrinaggio in terra santa per i cristiani del Medioevo voleva anche dire
assumersi consapevolmente il rischio di fare la stessa fine, per dirlo in modo un po' brutale.
Sapere che si stava partendo per fare una cosa pericolosa, faticosa, dolorosa, si stava via
da casa per anni, c'erano probabilità concrete di non tornarci, di lasciarci la pelle lungo la
strada, e tuttavia farlo. Farlo per immedesimazione con la passione di Cristo, farlo per penitenza,
farlo perché si pensava che la vita avesse un senso che andava al di là degli interessi
concreti quotidiani e che a volte quel senso bisognava rincorrerlo anche a rischio della
vita. O dunque, la crociata è un pellegrinaggio, però è un tipo di pellegrinaggio molto particolare
che comincia in un momento specifico. È un pellegrinaggio che ha lo scopo non solo
di andare a Gerusalemme a toccare con mano il Santo Sepolcro, ma ha lo scopo di andarci
armati, perché si teme che chi possiede Gerusalemme magari non ci lascerà venire o comunque ci
darà dei fastidi, andarci armati, aprire la strada in modo che tutti i pellegrini cristiani
in futuro ci possano andare senza pericolo e impadronirsi di Gerusalemme, in modo che
Gerusalemme sia in mani cristiane. La premessa, naturalmente, ci sono alcune coordinate geografiche
e cronologiche che dobbiamo dare per capirci. La premessa è che Gerusalemme è stata in mani
cristiane per secoli sotto l'impero bizantino, poi sono arrivati gli arabi con la grande espansione
dell'Islam dopo Maometto e hanno conquistato fra l'altro la Terra Santa. Uno potrebbe pensare
che in quel momento i cristiani abbiano pensato alla crociata come necessità per riprendere
il controllo dei luoghi santi, che erano così importanti nella loro prospettiva mentale.
In realtà non è così. Per molti secoli l'Occidente cristiano non ha né le forze e neanche la
voglia di intraprendere una riconquista armata. I rapporti con i musulmani che governano in Terra
Santa, che governano Gerusalemme, sono in genere discreti. Carlo Magno si scambia ambasciadori,
ambasciatori con il califo Arun al-Rashid, facendo delle convenzioni per essere sicuro che i
pellegrini cristiani possano andare liberamente, che non paghino troppi pedaggi e così via.
Invece a un certo momento, ed è davvero un momento cruciale nella storia dell'Occidente,
per vari motivi che proviamo anche a dire poi, i cristiani decidono che è necessario qualcos'altro,
che è necessario uno sforzo, di nuovo uno sforzo penoso, faticoso, sulla via di Cristo,
imitando la passione di Cristo, mettendosi in gioco interamente, per fare in modo che finisca
questo scandalo, come lo vedono loro, e che Gerusalemme sia di nuovo in mani cristiane.
Questa cosa ha una data molto precisa. Nell'anno 1095, un papa, Urbano II, decide di lanciare
questo progetto. Con tutta l'autorità morale del papato, invita i cristiani, i cattolici,
ad andare in terra santa, ad andarci in tanti, ad andarci armati, a prendere possesso dei luoghi
santi. Qui cominciano le crociate. Quindi le crociate sono la vicenda di quei cristiani
che hanno accettato l'appello del papa, che hanno sentito, e la loro mentalità funzionava
così. Hanno sentito con enorme forza il fascino di questo appello, si sono messi in
gioco, facendo cose che con i nostri valori di oggi ci sembrano assai discutibili, e che
invece a loro sembravano sacrosante, sono andati e hanno conquistato Gerusalemme. E questa
è la prima crociata, poi ce n'è tante altre, come mai? Ma perché? Ovviamente i musulmani
non sono rimasti inerti di fronte al fatto che un'orda di barbari venuti da chissà
dove, per di più pagani miscredenti, era venuta a conquistare in terra islamica una
delle città sante dell'Islam, cioè Gerusalemme. Ovviamente i musulmani hanno sentito come
un'enorme offesa, un'offesa a loro e un'offesa a Dio, il fatto che i miscredenti dell'Occidente
fossero venuti a impadronirsi di Gerusalemme, del sepolcro di Cristo, che anche per i musulmani
naturalmente è un grande profeta venerato, e quindi i musulmani si sono immediatamente
attrezzati per riconquistare Gerusalemme. Per questo molte crociate, perché i musulmani
lentamente riconquistano i territori presi dai crociati, i crociati continuano a alimentare
dall'Europa con nuove spedizioni la difesa di questi territori, e ci vogliono due secoli
perché poi finalmente i musulmani prevalgano e riescano a buttare a mare gli ultimi crociati.
Quali altri parametri sono necessari perché ci capiamo quando proviamo a andare poi un
po' più in profondità a raccontare alcuni aspetti delle crociate? Io direi questo. Per
molto tempo gli storici hanno detto, beh sì, si capisce, la propaganda diceva si tratta
di andare a conquistare i luoghi santi, la passione, il sepolcro di Cristo, ma in realtà
sotto c'erano profonde motivazioni politiche, economiche, desiderio di conquista, necessità
di sfogare la ricchezza anche demografica di un'Europa che stava crescendo, che era piena
di giovani. Allora era l'Europa che era piena di giovani e li mandava verso il Maghreb, verso
il Nord Africa e verso il Medio Oriente. Ecco, è tutto vero, però diciamo che forse noi
oggi siamo anche un po' più attrezzati rispetto a quello che erano gli storici dell'Ottocento
per esempio, per capire che forse un popolo, un'intera cultura, può davvero decidere che
il possesso di una città santa è una cosa fondamentale per cui vale la pena di rischiare
la vita. Anche oggi, per il possesso di Gerusalemme, ci sono popoli che si combattono e per carità
anche lì ci sono motivazioni economiche, politiche, però la sensazione ce l'abbiamo tutti che c'è
anche una motivazione religiosa abbastanza forte per spingere la gente a rischiare la
vita e a uccidere. Ecco, allora erano anche i cristiani che vedevano le cose in questi termini.
Dopodiché è vero che le crociate avvengono in un momento in cui l'Europa sta crescendo,
ha delle forze da spendere, ha della gente da mandare fuori perché in casa ormai le eredità
a forza di dividerle si sono rimpicciolite e quando un cavaliere ha un figlio solo va tutto
bene e l'eredità la prende il figlio, ma quando ne ha tre, quattro, cinque, qualcuno
deve andare a cercare fortuna in giro. E infatti la prima crociata si traduce anche con un'immensa
conquista territoriale. Io mi sono sempre tenuto sulle generiche, la Serra Santa, Gerusalemme,
i luoghi santi. I crociati che conquistano Gerusalemme nel 1099 e ci sono andati a piedi,
passando attraverso i Balcani e l'Asia minore, appena si sono trovati fuori dall'impero bizantino,
cristiano e in terra islamica, hanno cominciato non solo ad attraversare, ma a conquistare e
occupare stabilmente i territori che attraversavano. Quindi i crociati hanno messo in piedi un regno
che hanno chiamato Regno di Gerusalemme, certo, perché aveva una prospettiva comunque che si
legittimava nella dimensione ultraterrena, dove Gerusalemme era quello che contava. Però questo
regno, se uno lo guarda sulle cartine di oggi, equivale grosso modo a buona parte della Siria,
Giordania, Israele, Palestina, Libano. È un territorio, presto anche Cipro ci aggiungono,
è un territorio di notevolissima ampiezza. Tanto che oggi gli storici non si fanno tanto scopo di
dire in fondo quello è il primo esperimento coloniale europeo. È la prima volta che gli europei
provano a conquistare un territorio fuori dall'Europa occidentale e a impiantarci una
loro aristocrazia di padroni che comandano e governano. Dunque questa dimensione c'è.
E una delle sfide di queste tre lezioni sarà anche proprio questa, di provare a mantenerci in
equilibrio fra queste due dimensioni, di provare a immaginare questa gente che da un lato ci credeva
sul serio. Sul serio metteva in gioco la pelle per uno scopo che considerava gradito al suo Dio
e pensava di star seguendo le tracce di Cristo, rischiando la vita e subendo eventualmente il
martirio, e che però al tempo stesso sapeva anche benissimo che quella era una straordinaria
occasione di conquista, di arricchimento, una straordinaria occasione per partire da casa e
andare a occupare una posizione più alta nel nuovo mondo conquistato, nell'oltremare come lo
chiamavano. Ecco la compresenza dell'entusiasmo religioso, che per molti di noi oggi può essere
magari difficile da comprendere in quella dimensione, e che però c'era, saremmo dei cattivi storici se
ci immaginassimo che loro non ce l'avevano questo, ecco ce l'avevano e come. La compresenza di questo,
con l'avidità sfrenata, il desiderio di conquista più spudorato, è una delle cose che
sono difficili da accettare, e che invece io cercherò in qualche modo di far vedere con
degli esempi. La crociata per parecchio tempo, per parecchie generazioni, è una cosa ben fissa
nella testa della gente. Gli occidentali per più di un secolo sono disposti senza discutere
a mettere in ballo risorse, potenza militare, denaro, vite, tutti, dal re, dall'imperatore
fino all'ultimo dei contadini, per questo scopo collettivo che tutti sentono come uno
scopo collettivo, difendere i luoghi santi. E la crociata in questo senso è una cosa onnipervasiva,
non sono solo le grandi spedizioni che noi numeriamo, quelle dove partono i re e gli imperatori,
la seconda, la terza, la quarta, ma in realtà la gente parte continuamente. Chiunque può
decidere di partire e andare a dare una mano in terra santa a quelli che la stanno difendendo.
Chiunque può decidere, questo è già un po' più comodo, però anche questo costa, di lasciare
per testamento dei soldi per pagare dei combattenti che vadano in terra santa. È un ideale condiviso,
è largamente praticato. Poi col tempo pian piano ci accorgiamo che la gente a questo
ideale comincia a pensarci un po' meno, per tanti motivi. Uno è che le cose stanno andando
malissimo comunque, perché la riconquista musulmana in realtà procede e nonostante gli
enormi sforzi dell'Occidente viene solo ritardata progressivamente, però le cose vanno male.
Ma questo forse non basterebbe. Un altro motivo è che la crociata è diventata un'istituzione,
che a volte le autorità gestiscono con disinvoltura. Ecco, questo è ancora un parametro che dovevo
ricordarvi di darvi, facciamo adesso. Per parlare di crociata, dobbiamo aver presente che la crociata
diventa quasi subito, dopo la prima, quando si capisce che ce ne vorranno altre, diventa anche
un'istituzione giuridica dell'Occidente. Mi spiego cosa vuol dire questo. Vuol dire che una
spedizione è una crociata, quando l'unica autorità morale che tutti i cristiani d'Occidente
riconoscono in quei secoli, e che li accomuna tutti, quella del Papa, che può essere criticato
come singola persona, con cui si può non andare d'accordo, ma che però, in quanto Papa, è un'autorità
morale riconosciuta da tutti. Ecco, si ha la crociata quando il Papa dice che una spedizione
è una crociata, che tutti quelli che partiranno d'ora in poi, nei prossimi mesi, sono ufficialmente
crociati, ed essere ufficialmente crociati diventa uno statuto giuridico, nel senso che
la Chiesa mette in ballo la sua autorità per ottenere che tutti i poteri, tutti i re, i
comuni, i principi, riconoscano dei privilegi a chi parte. Piccoli privilegi, per carità, privilegi
necessari. Se parti, il pagamento dei tuoi debiti è dilazionato, non verranno a confiscarti
la mandria o la casa mentre sei via. Se muori, c'è una tutela giuridica speciale sul tuo
testamento, dovunque tu muoia, per essere sicuri che la tua famiglia è garantita. Privilegi
sufficienti per far sì che essere crociato sia, appunto, uno status giuridico, e la crociata
è in questo senso, dicevo, una istituzione. Ma perché vi dicevo che questa cosa, in realtà,
alla lunga è uno dei motivi per cui l'entusiasmo di molta gente comincia a diminuire? Perché quello
che succede è che la crociata, l'abbiamo detto, può essere proclamata solo dal Papa. E il Papa è
una grande autorità morale che ha in questi secoli uno scopo ben preciso, cioè quello di imporsi come
arbitro della politica europea, di convincere tutti i sovrani, tutti gli stati, ad accettare il suo
primato. Il periodo delle crociate, da fine undicesimo secolo, 1099, la conquista di Gerusalemme,
fino alla fine del duecento, è anche il periodo in cui i Papi seriamente stanno provando, è l'unico
periodo nella storia d'Europa, finora, in cui i Papi seriamente siano stati abbastanza riconosciuti
come un'autorità a cui anche i re e gli imperatori, sia pure un po' ma volentieri, erano disposti a
ubbidire in molte cose. Allora, qualche Papa, i Papi però hanno sempre anche degli avversari,
pensate ai lunghi conflitti tra il Papato e l'Impero, che sono tipici del Medioevo, ecco,
a un certo punto qualche Papa non resiste alla tentazione. Abbiamo dei nemici interni, abbiamo
l'imperatore Federico II che è un malvagio, ghibellino, senza Dio, protegge gli eretici, e i buoni
cristiani vanno a farsi ammazzare in terra santa, combattendo contro gli infedeli, ma
se li abbiamo in casa, i malvagi, perché non potremmo proclamare la crociata anche contro
di loro? Si può immaginare che ne abbiano discusso, Papi, Cardinali, ma non ne hanno
discusso molto, hanno quasi subito deciso che sì, si poteva fare, perché no? Un imperatore
nemico del Papa, oppure una banda di eretici in Provenza o in Lombardia, erano altrettanto
nemici di Dio, dei musulmani laggiù, oltremare, e quindi i Papi cominciano a proclamare crociate
contro i loro nemici interni. A questo punto capite cosa vuol dire, è una cosa molto concreta,
chi va ha diritto a certi privilegi, ma anche a certi finanziamenti si intende, perché il
discorso delle crociate, le crociate costano, anche le Medioevo ci vogliono i soldi per fare
la guerra, ogni crociata vuol dire complicati negoziati tra la Chiesa e il Re per decidere
quanto mettete voi? Eh, il Regno di Francia può mettere tanto, però i Vescovi contribuiscono,
ah no, i Vescovi non contribuiscono, sì, devono contribuire, e il Papa li convincerà
a contribuire. Allora, se c'è questo discorso sotto, anche le crociate contro l'imperatore
Ghibellino, o contro gli eretici catari della lingua d'oca, vengono gestite e finanziate
in questo modo, e molti partono, pensando che c'è molto da guadagnare, anche lì ci sarà
da far bottino, e Dio per di più è contento e si salva l'anima, però la gente di allora
non era né più ingenua né meno ingenua di noi oggi. Anche allora c'è qualcuno che
comincia a dire, sì, comodo però per il Papa proclamare la crociata ogni volta che
gli fa comodo. Un conto è la crociata per andare a vivere in terra santa la passione
di Cristo, un conto è andare a massacrare questi poveracci di eretici che non siamo neanche
ben sicuri di chi siano, oppure combattere l'imperatore che dice il Papa è un nemico
della sede, ma guarda caso l'imperatore invece sostiene di essere lui il vero leader della
cristianità. Non la faccio lunga. Questo è certamente uno dei motivi per cui l'entusiasmo
per le crociate complessivamente comincia a diminuire. E poi ce n'è anche altri, molto
rapidamente. Succede che a un certo punto arriva uno dall'Italia e va in terra santa e attraversa
gli accampamenti dei crociati e alziché fermarsi lì e dire sono qua, ditemi quando c'è da
menare le mani, va un po' più in là, entra nell'accampamento dei musulmani, chiede del
sultano e dice io sono venuto qua per discutere col sultano, si chiamava San Francesco. Era
uno molto discusso a suo tempo, finché era vivo, poi dopo morto l'hanno canonizzato,
finché era vivo dava molto fastidio, una delle cose che ha fatto che è andato più fastidio
è stata di andare in terra santa e poi una volta lì dire guardate che non si deve combattere
questa gente, discutiamoci. Un altro indizio di un cambiamento di atteggiamento è appunto
l'imperatore Federico II, non per niente il papa si è seccato con lui, il quale a un certo
punto accetta di fare la crociata, va bene, sono un imperatore, un sovrano cristiano, devo
fare questa cosa, è un dovere, la faccio, vado. E una volta arrivato in terra santa
va dal sultano e gli dice ma non potremmo metterci d'accordo. Quanto costa recuperare
Gerusalemme. E per un momento ci sta anche riuscendo, salvo che appunto ci sono forze
potenti come potete immaginare che non trovano giusto risolvere la cosa in questo modo, sia
da una parte sia dall'altra. Ecco, ho tratteggiato, perdendo già un sacco di tempo, un insieme
di aspetti che ci fanno capire cosa è stata la crociata e perché l'ideale della crociata
è tramontato a un certo punto. D'accordo? A fine 200, quando intanto i musulmani hanno
finito la riconquista e buttato a mare le ultime retroguardie cristiane, in Europa l'entusiasmo
non è più poco di una volta. E dunque il fenomeno crociato, nella prospettiva in cui lo conosciamo
nel medioevo, tramonta. Si conclude. Ora noi in queste tre serate esamineremo diversi
aspetti del fenomeno crociato in modo un po' più dettagliato. Parleremo di come i cristiani
hanno cominciato a un certo punto a pensare che la guerra possa essere santa, quando invece
i primi cristiani avevano idee del tutto diverse su questo. E parleremo di come in questa prospettiva
anche il mondo musulmano ha riscoperto quelle idee della jihad che ci sono, sì, nel Corano,
ma che per molto tempo erano state abbastanza dimenticate e che invece proprio con le crociate
riacquistano circolazione. Parleremo anche di come le crociate sono una straordinaria occasione
per noi, che studiamo quel periodo, di vedere i nostri antenati con gli occhi degli altri.
Perché le crociate sono la prima occasione in cui in folla gli occidentali vanno fuori,
incontrano i bizantini, incontrano gli arabi, i turchi, i musulmani e tutta questa gente
osserva, con una certa costernazione devo dire in genere, gli occidentali e li descrive,
e scrive libri e lettere e trattati per raccontare chi sono questi stranissimi barbari.
E per noi ovviamente è una bella occasione vedere con gli occhi degli altri il nostro
mondo, la nostra società medievale. Questo domani e dopo domani. Io questa sera però
vorrei provare a fare ancora invece una cosa un po' diversa. Io vorrei provare adesso a
calarmi, come dire, le cautele le ho avanzate tutte. Adesso vorrei provare per un attimo
a calarmi invece nella mentalità di quegli occidentali del Medioevo che la crociata la
apprezzavano in blocco, senza discussione, e vedere come mai, in che modo, in modi diversi,
alcuni grandi personaggi della nostra storia sono diventati grandi personaggi proprio attraverso
la partecipazione alle crociate. In altre parole vorrei fermarmi sul fatto che il giudizio sulle
crociate cambia nel tempo, però la grande maggioranza di noi ha sentito parlare di Goffredo
di Buglione. Ha sentito parlare di Riccardo Cuor di Leone. Ecco, e come mai? Perché sono
andati alle crociate. Ma chi erano costoro esattamente? E come mai sono diventati dei
modelli, degli esempi, dei personaggi che per generazioni sono stati ricordati?
Su Goffredo di Buglione devo dire, dirò pochissimo. Goffredo di Buglione è uno dei
leader della prima crociata. Della prima crociata forse potremmo dire ancora questo, che non abbiamo
finora detto. Il Papa Urbano II la lancia in un momento in cui sta puntando decisamente a essere
lui il Papa il leader dell'Occidente. Questo anche perché quello è il momento intorno al 1000, i secoli
a cavallo dell'anno 1000, è il momento in cui in Occidente lo Stato invece è più debole. I re ci sono,
ma sono debolissimi. Il potere è tutto gestito dai signori locali nei loro castelli, oppure da principi
che possiedono magari tanti castelli in una certa zona. Ecco, se fossimo qui mille anni fa ci sarebbero
i Malaspina, va bene, ci sono i Malaspina. Comandano in Lunigiana e fin verso Genova, d'accordo,
principi regionali, certo non re. Ecco, in quell'epoca il potere è gestito tutto a quel livello.
C'era un sovrano più potente degli altri, l'imperatore, è appena uscito da quel capitolo
di storia che tutti ricordiamo, che l'ha un po' traumatizzato, della lotta per le investiture.
Ricordate Enrico IV, a Canossa, a Piediscalzi, ecco. Dopo un trauma come quello del conflitto col papato,
anche l'imperatore è debolissimo. Perché vi dico questo? Per un solo motivo. La prima crociata è l'unica
a cui non partecipa nessun re, e neanche l'imperatore. Perché sono ridotti molto male
in quel momento. Non per niente il papa sceglie proprio quel momento per venire fuori e organizzare
lui una grande impresa collettiva di tutta l'Europa cristiana. I re non sono più dei concorrenti.
C'è il papa e ci sono i principi locali che comandano a livello regionale, e sono questi che partono.
Conte di Tolosa, Bohemondo d'Altavilla e Normanno, che possedeva un pezzo d'Italia meridionale,
altri, molti conti, duchi, francesi, che possiedono ciascuno una regione, magari la Borgogna, magari
la Normandia. Ecco, uno di questi è Goffredo di Buglione, della famiglia dei duchi di Lorena. Uno
fra i tanti. Di questi tanti noi non sappiamo quasi niente. Non abbiamo, per quell'epoca non
abbiamo ancora, che ne sono lettere private, per esempio, di un re. Non abbiamo testimonianze
un po' libere di qualcuno che se li descriva anche nel privato, come avremo più tardi.
Io poi vi parlerò di Luigi Nono il Santo, per esempio. Luigi Nono il Santo abbiamo dei
racconti di amici suoi intimi, che ci raccontano i dettagli più personali, ma è passato del
tempo. Nell'undicesimo secolo, quando parte la prima crociata, roba del genere non c'è.
È un'Europa molto arretrata ancora, quella. E lo vediamo proprio dalle fonti che ci lascia.
Goffredo di Buglione, come tutti gli altri, chi fosse in cuor suo non lo sappiamo. Sappiamo
che è diventato famoso perché fra i tanti che sono partiti è quello che poi alla fine,
quando hanno conquistato Gerusalemme, erano tre anni che erano lontani da casa, e avevano
già rischiato la pelle tutti quanti parecchie volte, e adesso ce l'avevano fatta. Avevano
conquistato Gerusalemme, cavalcato con i loro cavalli nelle strade della città e nella
moschea, con il sangue che arrivava fino alle ginocchia dei cavalli, e adesso si trovavano
a aver conquistato questo immenso paese, immenso dal loro punto di vista, piuttosto grande
effettivamente, dalla Turchia fino all'Egitto. E cosa ne facciamo di questo paese? Torniamo
a casa adesso, ma nemmeno per idea. Restiamo qua a governarlo, questo nuovo regno che abbiamo
conquistato per Dio e per Cristo. Come lo organizziamo? Vi ho appena detto che i re non contavano
niente, chi comandavano i principi, proprio per quello decidono di fare un re. In questo
modo tutti i capi potranno continuare ciascuno a comandare un pezzo del territorio, ma ci sarà
un primus inter pares che conterà molto poco, che però avrà quella sacralità che i re
hanno, perché il re è una figura consacrata. Noi non sappiamo niente di come l'hanno scelto,
possiamo solo immaginare le discussioni. Non sappiamo se hanno scelto il più coraggioso,
che è la versione ufficiale, o quello che dava meno fastidio di tutti, o quello che
salva già un po' male di salute, infatti poi è morto quasi subito, non ne sappiamo
niente. Però scelgono Goffredo di Buglione, che quindi è il primo re di Gerusalemme, l'anno
dopo muore. Basta, basta evidentemente, è il primo re di Gerusalemme. Poi vabbè, il
tasso qualche secolo dopo dà una mano per costruire evidentemente un mito che rimane
radicato nel nostro immaginario. Però Goffredo di Buglione è questo, io con tutta la buona
volontà di più non vi potrei dire, è un po' poco come vedete. Vi vorrei parlare un
po' più a lungo di un altro esempio invece, di eroe che attraversa il periodo, che emerge
dal periodo delle crociate. Ho citato prima Riccardo Cordileone, lo lascerei per dopo.
Vorrei fermarmi di più su un altro re che magari è un pochino meno conosciuto, però
anche lui l'abbiamo sentito, Luigi IX di Francia, Luigi il Santo, San Luigi dei Francesi.
il re santo del 200 francese. Luigi IX è un personaggio straordinario che incarna in
pieno l'ideale della crociata, in un momento in cui intorno a lui c'è già qualcuno che
comincia a non crederci più tanto. È il personaggio non di uno che non ha niente da perdere, ma
di uno che ha un regno da perdere e decide di metterlo in gioco per andare a Gerusalemme.
Ed è, grande fortuna per chi fa il mio mestiere, il protagonista di molti racconti, narrazioni
storiche. È un personaggio che ha lasciato un grande impatto su chi l'ha conosciuto, si
sapeva benissimo che era un santo. A volte faceva un po' perdere la patienza proprio per
questo, ma era uno diverso dagli altri. Chi l'ha conosciuto si è messo subito a scrivere.
Io l'ho conosciuto, è successo questo, quest'altro, l'ho visto, seduto per terra che rendeva
giustizia, gli ho parlato, gli ho raccontato questa cosa e lui si è messo a ridere. Abbiamo
molti scritti di questo tipo su Luigi il Santo che ci permettono di costruire l'immagine
di quello che è stato considerato da tutti i suoi contemporanei l'esempio massimo di eroe
della crociata. Chi era Luigi? Luigi è uno che vive la crociata molto chiaramente nel
senso di un pellegrinaggio penitenziale. Bisogna andare a conquistare Gerusalemme, è un obbligo,
bisogna farlo e più soffriamo, più rischiamo la vita nel farlo, anche se non vorremmo, perché
non è un matto che sia disposto a farsi ammazzare per il martire, è tutt'altro. In una situazione
pericolosa in terra santa, uno va a dirgli ma forse faremmo meglio a metterci al sicuro,
non siamo mica venuti qua per farci ammazzare tutti, e lui, Luigi, lo guarda e gli fa guarda
che non c'è nessuno che ama la vita più di me. Però, per un re cristiano, è un dovere.
Si è chiaro, io sto cercando di esprimere il pathos con cui loro vivevano queste cose,
noi poi possiamo dire atteggiamenti molto lontani dai nostri, però di cui credo dobbiamo
condividere con i nostri antenati il senso che si trattava di cose grosse, importanti
per loro. Luigi, dunque, è uno che vive la crociata come un momento di sofferenza, di
umiliazione, di penitenza. È uno che quando decide di andare a liberare la terra santa,
da un lato deve mettere in piedi un grande meccanismo militare, finanziario, trovare risorse,
svuota il tesoro dello Stato, recluta cavalieri, trova le navi, costruisce un porto apposta,
Egmort, sulla costa della Francia meridionale. Però al tempo stesso va poi a imbarcarsi, attraversando
il suo regno di Francia, a piedi, spesso facendo scalzo il tratto da una chiesa a un santuario,
e comunque a piedi, vestito da pellegrino, col bastone, la bisaccia, niente abiti sontuosi,
eccetera. E la gente è lì che lo guarda, stupefatta, perché appunto, come vi dicevo,
ormai c'è già qualcuno che non ci crede più così tanto, e vedere un re che invece
si crede fino a questo punto, ecco, convince tutti che è un santo. È lì che cominciano
tutti a dire, non è mica una persona normale quello lì.
C'è un racconto di un frate italiano che si chiama Salimbene, da Parma, cronista molto
divertente di allora, un francescano che era in Francia, in un convento, a Sons, dove
si teneva il capitolo generale dell'ordine francescano, e il re passa di lì, durante
il suo viaggio per andare a imbarcarsi per la crociata. E Salimbene racconta, beh, si
sapeva che doveva arrivare il tale mattino, voleva parlare ai frati, quindi tutti gli sono
andati incontro. Su questo non c'entra con la crociata, ma diciamolo lo stesso, Salimbene
dice, c'era un frate particolarmente importante nel convento, frate Eudrigo, che era anche
arcivescovo di Rouen, e quindi lui per andare incontro al re voleva andare con tutti i suoi
paramenti di arcivescovo, e quindi la mitria e il pastorale e ha perso tempo a prepararsi.
Quando è stato pronto erano già tutti usciti, e allora io l'ho visto che si precipitava
fuori con la mitria e il pastorale gridando, dov'è il re, dov'è il re? E tutti gli altri
erano già tutti sulla strada che guardavano dove stava arrivando il re. E l'hanno visto
arrivare a piedi col bastone da pellegrino, che poi dice, vi voglio parlare, lo fanno
entrare nella chiesa che ha un pavimento di terra battuta ancora, gli vogliono portare
delle panche, e lui dice, ma no, ci sediamo per terra. E si siede per terra e parla ai frati
e gli dice che ha bisogno del loro aiuto. E lì più smaliziati cominciano a preoccuparsi
perché quando il re chiede alla chiesa un aiuto spesso bisogna mettere mano al tesoro,
e invece il re dice subito, no no, io vado solo a mie spese, sto spendendo soltanto del
mio, l'aiuto che mi serve sono le vostre preghiere. E dice Salimbene, che era presente,
italiano. I frati francesi piangevano tutti.
Luigi è uno che ha fatto voto di andare incrociata, c'è andato due volte, la prima volta ha rischiato
di lasciarci la pelle, e c'è morta un'infinità di gente, la seconda volta c'ha lasciato la
pelle sul serio, la prima volta era ancora giovane, ha fatto voto di andare incrociata
perché era stato molto malato e durante la malattia aveva avuto delle visioni, e quando
si riprende dalla malattia dice io ho fatto voto di andare, di prendere la croce e di andare
a liberare il sepolcro. Nel frattempo i musulmani l'hanno già riconquistato, il santo sepolcro,
quindi si tratta di nuovo di liberarlo. Ho fatto questo voto e dice, com'è che dice,
è una frase molto bella, dice il mio spirito sta pensando alle visioni che ha avuto, al
delirio, è stato in punto di morte, il mio spirito è stato a lungo, al di là del mare,
e ora questo mio corpo se ne andrà laggiù. Dopodiché sua madre e il vescovo di Parigi cercano
di convincerlo che siccome l'ha fatto nel delirio il voto non è buono e non c'è bisogno
che vada. E lui, che si è già fatto cucire sull'abito la croce, che era il simbolo dei
crociati, si chiamano così perché si fanno cucire sull'abito la croce, lui si strappa
dal vestito la croce, la dà al vescovo e gli dice, adesso ridammela, che voglio che tutti
vedano che sono sano di mente nel momento in cui la prendo. Va? Non va interessante,
va in Egitto perché hanno fatto il calcolo strategico che conquistando l'Egitto si riesce
a interrompere i collegamenti interi al mondo musulmano e dopo Gerusalemme cadrà da sola.
In realtà in Egitto sbarcano, hanno però delle grandissime difficoltà, alla fine vengono
sbaragliati. Molti morti, il re viene catturato, deve pagare un grosso riscatto, dopo quando i
musulmani liberano i prigionieri bisogna tornare indietro, è complicatissimo, ci vogliono
anni, è un'esperienza tragica tra malattie, epidemie, il re la vive in pieno con tutto
il suo corpo, c'è la dissenteria nell'accampamento, il re soffre di dissenteria come tutti gli altri,
sviene spesso, ha una dissenteria tale che, dice il cronista, a un certo punto hanno dovuto
tagliargli il fondo delle braghe per facilitare le cose e gli dicono ma vai su una delle galere,
vai sulle navi dove puoi essere al sicuro almeno, lui dice no il mio popolo è qui, sono
qui, stanno morendo qui, resto qui anch'io per capire il tipo sempre. A un certo punto
ci sono dei cadaveri insepolti di cristiani che sono stati uccisi in combattimento, nessuno
li ha seppelliti, il re va e dice li seppellisco io, chiama i suoi amici e dice andiamo a seppellire
quei martiri, loro hanno sofferto la morte, noi possiamo anche sopportare il fastidio di
seppellire i loro corpi e non abbiate ripugnanza per questi corpi perché sono martiri in paradiso.
Un santo, infatti tutti intorno a lui sono sballorditi, sia ben chiaro non sto descrivendo
il comportamento normale di tutti i crociati, sto descrivendo un comportamento che incarna in
pieno gli ideali crociati ma che i suoi stessi contemporanei giudicano qualcosa di abbastanza
sballorditivo, è però un uomo complicato, complicato, con sfumature. A un certo punto
nell'accampamento passano dei pellegrini armeni, cristiani d'oriente, che stanno andando a
Gerusalemme, che stanno andando con un salvacondotto del sultano il quale se la gente arriva pacifica
la lascia andare a Gerusalemme, sono solo quelli che arrivano armati che vengono combattuti
e in genere sconfitti. Aperta parentesi, anche a Luigi IX il sultano ha offerto, dopo
averlo sconfitto, di andare con un salvacondotto in pellegrinaggio a Gerusalemme. Ci tengono
tanto, lo facciamo andare. E Luigi IX ci terrebbe davvero tanto e si tormenta e poi alla fine
decide di non andare. Perché dice, se io, che sono il re di Francia, accetto un salvacondotto
per andare a Gerusalemme e non la conquisto, vado solo a vedere, poi torno, chi altri andrà
mai a cercare di conquistarla? Tutti penseranno che se basta quello che ho fatto io, lo faranno
anche loro. E non ci va. Perché lui la vuole conquistare. Perché questo, questa specie di
frate da tanti punti di vista, sembra San Francesco in molte cose, il martirio, i cadaveri, stare
in mezzo alla gente che soffre. Però, a noi può sembrare una contraddizione, non lo
è, perché è un crociato. I biografi lo descrivono anche al momento dello sbarco, quando finalmente
sono arrivati davanti alle spiagge e i battelli da sbarco si sono aperti, i cavaliere
hanno cominciato a scendere, a sguazzare nell'acqua, a prendere possesso della spiaggia
e Luigi era in mezzo a loro, a cavallo, in armatura, con un elmo d'oro, il più bel cavaliere
che abbia mai visto, dice uno dei cronisti. E siccome ci sono alcuni arabi che controllano
la scena da lontano, Luigi non resiste, scende giù a cavallo e da solo sprona con la lancia
in resta contro questi. Lo trattengono a fatica, perché lui è il re. Quindi, come vedete,
un crociato è sempre due cose insieme. Uno che sta comportandosi con un atteggiamento
quasi da frate francescano, da un certo punto di vista, e dall'altro un guerriero che è
andato lì per menare le mani. Ma vi dicevo che c'è anche, appunto, ci sono aspetti
che ci lasciano ancora più stupiti. L'autoironia sua è di quelli intorno a lui. Uno dei biografi
di cui vi parlavo è uno che l'ha conosciuto bene, un grosso nobile francese che ha avuto
incarichi ai suoi ordini, ha scritto un grosso libro con tutti gli aneddoti che ha potuto
ricordarsi della vita di San Luigi. Si chiama Joanville, questo signore. E Joanville dice
sì, durante la crociata, a un certo punto, nell'accampamento, sono passati questi pellegrini
che vi dicevo, armeni che andavano a Gerusalemme, cristiani d'Oriente. E questi cristiani d'Oriente
sapevano che il capo dei crociati europei era un grande santo, un re santo. Lo sapevano
e si sono fatti indicare la tenda e sono andati tutti lì. E davanti alla tenda c'era Joanville.
E loro gli chiedono di vedere il re santo. E Joanville, che il re lo vede tutti i giorni,
lo conosce benissimo, conosce tutti i suoi difetti e le sue debolezze, sa che è un santo,
lo ammira enormemente, però ci discute anche, ci litiga anche più di una volta.
Ecco, Joanville entra e fa il re. Sì, re. Lì fuori c'è una folla di gente che dicono
che vogliono vedere il re santo. Ma io non ho mica ancora voglia di baciare le vostre ossa.
Cosa vuol dire baciare le vostre ossa? Immaginate la loro logica, il culto delle reliquie,
che per loro è una cosa ovvia. Il santo, in che forma uno incontra i santi? Perché nelle
chiese ci sono le reliquie, le ossa spesso dei santi. E si baciano, ci si inginocchia e
si baciano le reliquie. Questa frase, che a noi non dice quasi niente, non ho ancora voglia
di baciare le vostre ossa, per loro dice tutto. Sarai anche un santo, magari sì, ma intanto
sei vivo e speriamo che quel giorno sei il più lontano possibile.
E poi c'è anche comunque quella misura di dubbio, diciamo, voglio dire, i santi
vivi, ma i santi sono morti da tanto tempo di solito. E il re, dice Giovenville, si mise
a ridere fragorosamente. Era il primo che non aveva voglia di andare in giro dicendo
io sono il santo e farsi adorare come santo.
dopodiché, quando muore, durante la sua seconda e ultima crociata, dove molti non
hanno più voluto accompagnarlo, perché intanto sono passati ancora altri anni, ormai siamo
nel 1270, l'ideale crociato davvero ormai non attira più molta gente. Molti che sono andati
con lui la prima volta e hanno visto com'è finita, non hanno più voglia di accompagnarlo,
anzi, quando fa sapere che vuole partire nel Regno di Francia si diffonde una certa
costernazione all'idea. Lui parte lo stesso, va, lo stesso Giovenville non ci va, poi lo
scrive nel libro, sì, sono un po' pentito, avrei dovuto andare, ma come si fa, insomma,
quello era un santo e lui c'è andato. C'è andato, si ammala, delirio, morte, prima di
morire nel delirio dice, dobbiamo mandare dei predicatori per convertirli, conosco dei
predicatori così bravi, dobbiamo mandare quelli per convertirli. E uno non sa se sta
soltanto delirando o se forse l'esempio di San Francesco, che ormai è passato tanto
tempo, comincia a funzionare anche a quel livello. Ecco, qui siamo veramente alla fine
dell'ideale crociato nel senso che è stato quello vero. Un ideale, cioè, che riusciva
a unire questo enorme spirito di sacrificio, il fascino enorme che loro provavano per chi
andava, insieme con nostro sconcerto, ovviamente, perché i nostri valori sono ben diversi, insieme
con l'idea ben ferma che si va armati a massacrare, a conquistare, a sottomettere, a
sbaragliare. Ecco, Luigi IX, che sul letto di morte dice, conosco dei predicatori bravissimi,
è veramente, in qualche modo, l'icona dell'ideale crociato che sta davvero finendo.
E' Riccardo Cordileone, allora. E' Riccardo Cordileone che è noto, credo, ancora più di
Luigi il Santo a tutti noi, in parte è colpa di Walter Scott, suppongo, e poi di tutta
la saga di Robin Hood, fino ai cartoni animati di Walt Disney. Riccardo Cordileone, che ovviamente
fa pandan con il cattivo re Giovanni, Giovanni senza terra. Queste sono figure che abbiamo
in mente un po' tutti. Riccardo Cordileone è un eroe coraggioso, mentre Giovanni senza
terra, suo fratello, lo sappiamo, è invece un cattivo vigliacco. E Riccardo Cordileone
è così famoso, ed è stato poi scelto da Walter Scott come eroe dei suoi romanzi, perché
è stato uno dei protagonisti delle crociate. Prima di Luigi IX, terza crociata, fine XII secolo,
una delle più grandi, più impegnative. In questa terza crociata Riccardo Cordileone
va. In un momento in cui le sorti del Regno di Gerusalemme sono al livello più basso,
sta andando tutto veramente molto male, il Saladino ha riconquistato Gerusalemme, ormai
restano solo più brandelli di Regno da difendere, qualche porto, si fa una grande crociata, Riccardo
Cordileone, re d'Inghilterra, parte, e in quella crociata è l'unico che si dimostra capace
di tenere testa sul campo al Saladino. È l'unico comandante crociato che in campo aperto
una volta sconfigge Saladino in battaglia, dopo che molti erano stati sconfitti. Assedia
città, le conquista, sparge il terrore, si fa vedere da tutti in battaglia, non come
Luigi il Santo che si faceva prendere l'entusiasmo, però poi combattuto poco perché è stato
sconfitto subito. Riccardo Cordileone vince, continua a vincere, combatte, è sempre in mezzo
ai cavalieri, lui personalmente con la spada in pugno, l'armatura coperta di sangue, e tutti
lo guardano e dicono, ma che bravo, che meraviglia, questo è un vero uomo, questo è un vero
re, un vero leone, cuore di leone, ora è tutto vero. Era un grande guerriera, nel senso
che noi sappiamo che anche in Europa, prima di partire per la crociata, è stato uno dei
re d'Inghilterra che hanno combattuto di più, nemici ne trovava sempre, vassalli
ribelli da sottomettere, suo fratello Giovanni, il re di Francia, ha combattuto per tutta
la vita. Noi sappiamo anche un po' di altre cose su Riccardo Cordileone. Ha combattuto
per tutta la vita, mettendosi in gioco personalmente, gli piaceva molto, era un grande combattente,
ha ammazzato un sacco di gente di mano sua, ha massacrato prigionieri in moltissime occasioni,
impiccato, affogato, prigionieri a decine o a centinaia, sia cristiani, sia poi, con ancora
maggior soddisfazione, musulmani in terra santa. Era odiato dal suo popolo, intanto perché
era francese. Come mai il re d'Inghilterra fosse un francese, non sto a raccontarlo perché
è troppo complesso, ma comunque era francese, che che ne dicano Walter Scott e Romando di
Ivano. Era odiato dal suo popolo perché imponeva tasse terrificanti, non era Giovanni,
era Riccardo che imponeva tasse terrificanti per finanziare le sue guerre. Era conosciuto
da tutti come un sovrano crudele, feroce, oppressivo, ma un grande guerriero e questo
la gente piaceva. Quando poi quel grande guerriero, con sollievo di molti, lascia l'Europa
per andare a combattere gli infedeli, l'eroe è fatto. Perché le crociate sono anche proprio
questo. Sono state pensate anche per questo. Quando noi leggiamo gli appelli alle crociate
da Urbano II in poi, o i trattati sulle crociate, sul fatto che è obbligatorio per i re, per i
principi, per i cavalieri andare alle crociate, ecco quello che pensano gli ecclesiastici, che
sono gli intellettuali di quell'epoca, è proprio questo. Questi nostri re, principi, cavalieri
che comandano, riscuotono le tasse, rendono giustizia, impiccano i malfattori e lo fanno
con durezza, con violenza, sono tutti armati, il potere è tutto militare e si combattono
fra loro continuamente e andranno tutti all'inferno, naturalmente, perché tutti hanno le mani bagnate
nel sangue. E se questa loro violenza pensano i chierici, che sono gli intellettuali del
Medioevo, se questa violenza dei potenti e dei ricchi noi riuscissimo a convogliarla
verso un fine buono, se li potessimo mandare in terra santa a combattere i nemici di Dio,
a difendere la cristianità laggiù, questo è la crociata anche. E quindi va benissimo,
chi in patria si è macchiato le mani di sangue e andrebbe all'inferno, quando fa la stessa
cosa. Oltre mare, invece, è un eroe. E Riccardo Cordileone rimane uno dei grandi eroi dell'Occidente,
dell'Europa, nonostante tutte quelle cose che abbiamo detto. Perché è un grande eroe? Perché
faceva una paura terribile ai musulmani. Gli aneddoti che corrono nella letteratura medievale
su Riccardo Cordileone sono di questo tipo. Molti scrittori lo raccontano. I saraceni avevano
così paura di Re Riccardo, che le mamme musulmane, per far star buoni i loro bambini
che piangevano, gli dicevano, guarda che viene Re Riccardo.
Dopodiché, appunto, mi avvio a chiudere, quello che mi sembra importante che noi cerchiamo
di capire è che molte generazioni di nostri antenati hanno condiviso questo blocco di idee,
di valori, di ideali, che ai nostri occhi sembrano in parte ideali magari stravaganti,
però affascinanti, forse. In parte, invece, non sembrano ideali proprio per niente. Per
loro non era una contraddizione. Per molto tempo, prima di cominciare a stancarsi e a non
crederci più, gli occidentali hanno creduto che fosse giusto cercare il martirio, che fosse
giusto seguire Cristo sulle tracce della passione, soffrire, rischiare la morte, uccidendo.
Per strappare ai nemici di Dio qualcosa che era considerato così prezioso. I luoghi
santi, il sepolcro. Sapendo perfettamente che se nel fare questo ci si arricchiva, si
conquistavano nuove terre, nuovi imperi, si diventava re, principi, questo non era una
contraddizione, anzi era il giusto premio. E quindi ancora più eroe chi è andato ed è
riuscito anche a diventare re, come Goffredo di Buglione. E vorrei chiudere evocando una
situazione specifica, quella di una famiglia di principi, questi principi territoriali che vi ho
ricordato così spesso, che sono quelli che più di tutti si sono avvantaggiati di queste
straordinarie occasioni di salvarsi l'anima e al tempo stesso vivere una grande avventura con
prospettive mirabolanti di successo. All'epoca di Riccardo Cordileone, che è anche l'epoca di
Federico Barbarossa, della battaglia di Legnano, della Lega Lombarda, in Italia c'era fra gli
altri un lignaggio di principi, erano i marchesi di Monferrato, dalle mie parti in Piemonte.
Erano di quelli che avevano molto da perdere con la crescita dei comuni cittadini e con la
sconfitta dell'imperatore, perché se crescono i comuni c'è meno spazio per i principi, per il
mondo rurale, per i nobili delle campagne. Proprio negli anni di Legnano il marchese di
Monferrato, Guglielmo il Vecchio, che ha quattro figli maschi, che sarebbero già troppi comunque
anche se le cose andassero bene, e che invece fa molta fatica a immaginare un futuro per loro
in un mondo in cui appunto l'imperatore è stato sconfitto e le città trionfano, comincia
a pensare che per uno del suo rango c'è una via d'uscita, e questa via d'uscita è offerta
dall'oltremare. È come se le crociate avessero aperto un orizzonte che prima non esisteva
o era chiuso, e che invece adesso, almeno per i potenti, almeno per i principi, sui
poveracci e sui motivi per cui partivano sappiamo molto meno, ma certamente per i principi è
come se improvvisamente il mondo si fosse raddoppiato. Qui le cose vanno male, ma là
ci sono prospettive straordinarie, specialmente per un principe che ha dei bei figli, alti,
biondi e robusti. Cosa succedeva in quel momento nel regno di Gerusalemme? Il Saladino
stava appunto cominciando la sua riconquista, l'orizzonte si stava già abbastanza oscurando,
ed era tanto più oscuro in quanto il re di Gerusalemme, successore di Goffredo di Buglione,
era un ragazzino di 15 anni, malato di lebra, baldovino quarto, re di Gerusalemme, malato
di lebra, cioè di una malattia che all'epoca non si sapeva curare e che si temeva fosse
molto peggio di quello che è in realtà, si credeva una malattia terribilmente contagiosa,
cosa che invece pare non sia, ma certamente si aveva un orrore profondo della lebra e
in ogni caso non si guariva. Eppure lui era il re, la corona era capitata a lui per diritto
ereditario, anche se era chiaro che entro pochi anni sarebbe rimasto paralizzato e cieco
e poi sarebbe morto. E certamente non era pensabile che si trovasse una ragazza nobile
che si potesse accoppiare con lui per dargli un'erede, ma il re aveva due sorelle e dunque
era evidente a tutti che i mariti di quelle sorelle avrebbero potuto candidarsi per governare
il regno di Gerusalemme. E naturalmente i baroni del regno erano tutti in fila a vedere chi
avrebbe prevalso e sarebbe riuscito a strappare la mano di una di queste principesse, ma Baldovino
IV che a 15 anni il giovane re Lebroso pare che fosse un tipo molto in gamba, quel poco
che sappiamo di lui, non si fida dei baroni del regno, preferisce un marito per una delle
sue sorelle che venga da fuori e che possa garantire appoggi, conoscenze, alleanze sul
continente. Senza quelle il regno di Gerusalemme non ce la farebbe a tirare avanti. Morale si
mettono d'accordo, il marchese di Monferrato Guglielmo manda suo figlio, che si chiama Guglielmo
come lui, soprannominato lunga spada, a sposare Sibilla, la sorella del re Lebroso. Il giovane
Guglielmo arriva, i cronisti lo descrivono, molto bello, alto e biondo, i cavalieri medievali
sono tutti alti e biondi perché questo era il loro ideale, è anche vero che il marchese
di Monferrato erano medi tedeschi per matrimonio. Piace molto, sposa la ragazza, la mette subito
incinta, intanto banchetta, beve molto, dicono i cronisti, ma questo è normale perché un
uomo deve dimostrare che è un uomo, poi comincia a deperire, si ammala, in tre mesi muore.
Naturalmente i baroni d'oltremare cominciano tutti a guardarsi in faccia per vedere chi è
che ha tirato fuori il veleno dagli stipetti segreti, ma non si scopre mai niente. Del resto
molti di questi giovani biondi che arrivano dall'Europa in quei climi muoiono all'improvviso appena
arrivati, ci sono abituati. Ora la ragazza è incinta, nascerà quindi un'erede, infatti
nascerà, sarà Valdovino V, di Monferrato, re di Gerusalemme, ma deve ancora nascere.
E il giovane re Lebroso che intanto combatte, è ancora in grado di stare a cavallo in quel
momento e di combattere contro il Saladino e riesce anche a tenere testa al Saladino in
una battaglia, però sta peggiorando rapidamente, ci vuole un altro marito per una di queste
sorelle, sempre quella rimasta vedova che è la maggiore, quindi conta di più. E stavolta
arriva un altro pretendente europeo, Guido di Lusignano, dalla Francia, e la sposa. Anche
Guido di Lusignano viene da fuori, quindi i baroni del posto non sono per niente contenti,
ma non riescono a avvelenarlo comunque. Guido di Lusignano deve far vedere che lui è
un vero uomo, naturalmente. Perciò decide di andare a affrontare il Saladino e fermare
questa riconquista progressiva che sta strangolando il regno. Raduna l'esercito, tutti i membri
dell'ordine dei Templari, dell'ordine degli ospedali, tutti i baroni con i loro cavalieri,
i loro vassalli. Parte per andare a affrontare il Saladino, che è stato segnalato da qualche
parte in Galilea, attraversano la Galilea, piena estate, zona arida, stanno per arrivare
al lago di Tiberiade, quello dove Gesù camminò sulle acque, dove finalmente ci sarà da bere,
prima che arrivino il Saladino li attacca e li circonda senza acqua. Rimangono lì, il giorno
dopo si arrendono tutti quanti. Saladino fa tagliare la testa a quelli che in passato gli
avevano fatto qualche sgarbo e a quelli che gli stavano più antipatici, come i Templari,
che considerava dei fanatici, con gli altri negozi a un riscatto. Tra gli altri c'è anche
Guglielmo di Monferrato, il vecchio, il nonno del bambino che sta per nascere o che intanto
è nato forse in questi mesi, è venuto a prendersi cura dell'eredità evidentemente. Lui rimane
prigioniero per un po', nessuno paga un riscatto per lui. Comunque molti vengono liberati.
Il Saladino ha annientato l'esercito di Gerusalemme, è in grado di riconquittare l'intero
regno. Va avanti, in poche settimane occupa quasi tutto il regno, occupa Gerusalemme, che
non cadrà mai più in mani cristiane. Rimane soltanto un porto, San Giovanni d'Acri, dove
si sono rinchiusi gli ultimi cristiani in armi. In quel preciso momento arriva sulle
coste della Terra Santa un altro figlio del Marchese Guglielmo. Si chiama Corrado, è stato
anche lui a cercare fortuna in Oriente, a Costantinopoli, ha sposato una principessa
bizantina, ha represso una congiura per conto dell'imperatore, poi anche lui ha capito che
c'era rischio di essere avvelenato a restare troppo lì, è partito per la Terra Santa, senza
sapere niente di quello che è successo, della disfatta dell'esercito, del fatto che il
Saladino ha riconquistato tutto. Corrado arriva in nave, in un porto, che crede in mani cristiane,
entra in porto, sulla banchina ci sono delle sentinelle musulmane. Allora c'è questo
dialogo che per noi è sbalorditivo e che invece i cronisti raccontano come una cosa
del tutto ovvia. Corrado dice, non sappiamo in che lingua avrà avuto l'interprete, nasconde
di essere un principe, perché altri che era venuto a dare una mano in Terra Santa, se
non l'avrebbero arrestato evidentemente, e dice no, noi siamo dei mercanti cristiani,
siamo venuti a commerciare, abbiamo saputo che il Saladino ha conquistato tutto, e sicuri
della sua protezione veniamo a commerciare. E le guardie non fanno una piega, la cosa
è assolutamente normalissima, i mercanti vanno e commerciano e fanno affari comunque
sempre e nessuno li disturba. Per cui riprendono il mare, filano, vanno a sbarcare nell'unica
città che intanto si sono informati e ancora in mano cristiane San Giovanni d'Acri. E lì
ovviamente l'arrivo di Corrado di Monferrato, che è un combattente già conosciuto, un cavaliere
noto, viene accolto con entusiasmo. Lui si assume il compito di difendere la città,
raduna le poche forze disponibili, difende la città, il Saladino arriva alla sedia, non
riesce a prenderla. Il Saladino alla fine prova a convincere Corrado ad arrendersi, tira
fuori suo padre, il vecchio Marchese Guglielmo, che è ancora prigioniero, e gli dice guarda
che se non mi cedi la città condanno a morte tuo padre. E Corrado da una di quelle risposte
che poi naturalmente in tutti i mercati dell'Occidente vengono raccontate per generazioni e che suscitano
l'entusiasmo. Dice ma ha già vissuto molto a lungo mio padre. Saladino a questo punto trova
che veramente questa gente libera il Marchese lo stesso e lascia perdere. Finalmente Saladino
ha il colpo di genio, trova il modo di liberarsi di Corrado che nel frattempo ha compiuto altre
imprese, ha distrutto l'unica flotta egiziana che faticosamente Saladino è riuscito a costituire,
ma Corrado ha le galee genovesi e pisane e quindi sbaraglia le navi musulmane. Saladino
non ne può più, ma poi ha il colpo di genio. Lui ha ancora fra le mani il re Guido di
Lusignano, quello che ha sposato Sibilla e che ha portato l'esercito al disastro e che
è odiato da tutti. Lo libera gratis. Guido di Lusignano va a bussare alle porte di tiro
e dice io sono il re, adesso Corrado mi cedi il potere. E Corrado naturalmente ancora una
volta dagli spalti rifiuta. Gli dice tu hai portato l'esercito alla rovina, ti sei giocato
la corona, non hai più nessun diritto, perciò. Dopodiché però intanto si formano i partiti,
ci sono quelli che vorrebbero che effettivamente tornasse Guido, ci sono quelli che vogliono
Corrado. Dall'Europa i veri re, un po' stufi di questi fantocci in terra santa, decidono
che ora intervenire. Parte Riccardo Cordileone per esempio e partono altri re. Arrivano, combattono
per un po', Riccardo Cordileone guadagna grandi vittorie, inutili, non riescono a riconquistare
Gerusalemme, finalmente si stufano e se ne vanno via tutti. Corrado è rimasto, è l'unico
che è rimasto. I baroni alla fine si radunano e decidono che lui è l'unico che è degno di
essere re di Gerusalemme, aspettando che suo nipotino e il bambino baldovino diventi grande.
C'è l'accordo di tutti perché Corrado sia il coronato re di Gerusalemme. Il giorno
dopo, dopo pranzo, Corrado esce in strada, due assassini lo affrontano, lo accoltellano,
lo lasciano morto per terra e non diventerà mai re di Gerusalemme. Ora, perché vi racconto
questa storia? Perché secondo me noi dobbiamo anche, prima di fare cose che in qualche modo
secondo me parleranno di più ai nostri problemi di oggi, come discutere sul concetto di guerra
santa o di jihad. Prima di fare questo noi dobbiamo però avere un po' l'idea di quali
erano invece le idee, le fantasie, le immagini che i nostri antenati di allora avevano in
mente. E loro avevano in mente questo. Quando loro parlavano di crociate, pensavano certo
alla salvezza dell'anima, alla passione di Cristo, all'ideale, al sogno di andare a toccare
con le proprie mani il santo sepolcro, e al tempo stesso pensavano a questo mondo dove
potevano capitare queste cose, dove uno poteva partire e diventare re. Un altro fratello
di Corrado, Bonifacio, ma non ve lo racconto perché è troppo lungo, diventerà addirittura
imperatore di Costantinopoli, dopo essere partito per una crociata. E i suoi seguaci saranno
da un lato un po' pentiti, perché Costantinopoli non era proprio l'obiettivo della crociata,
dire il vero. Era un impero cristiano, loro l'hanno conquistato. Però non resistono.
Le canzoni dei loro trovatori sono piene di entusiasmo per l'impero che abbiamo conquistato
e siamo diventati tutti re e principi. Ecco, questa immensa avidità, che però appunto
si traduce in uno sforzo, in un desiderio di conquistare, di prendere, di arraffare,
di massacrare, mettendosi in gioco però fisicamente, rischiando la pelle, e sicuri che si sta facendo
una cosa benedetta da Dio, questa è, credo, l'essenza del fenomeno delle crociate. Insomma,
qualcosa che credo per noi può essere molto lontano, ma il mestiere mio è proprio quello
di cercare di raccontare e di capire un po' anche ciò che i nostri antenati avevano
di molto diverso da ciò che siamo noi oggi. Ecco, grazie.
Grazie.